i think this is the first motion capture
really it's funny how like none of it
panned out
the animation is so good
this episode is brought to you by
audible stick around at the end to see
how you can get a free 30-day trial
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react hope you're
enjoying your saturday morning cheerios
we have some
wonderful video clips which we'll
display before you
okay guys guys the new mortal kombat
trailer just dropped it's super violent
it's right up our alley i think we
should take a look
wait hold on before we even watch it
predictions you know how they they're
like we're gonna do like the epic white
stripes cover like it's like orchestral
and heavier
yeah it's like but the mortal kombat
theme
[Music]
gives more predictions uh sub-zero oh if
someone says get over here
this could be like the last line by the
way
you haven't seen scorpion for the whole
trailer and like who's that and like
get over here and that's the end of the
trailer
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
you know like they're sub-zero their
isopacks are great
[Music]
so far no mortal kombat theme
you called both of those things oh my
god
that part where he cuts him and then
freezes his blood and uses that as a
knife
it's like so cool it's not just how it
looks but just like there's some great
concepts in that
they do a really good job of getting the
translucent
almost like subsurface scattering effect
from blood i don't know if that's
tracked in or not it's hard to say that
could be a 3d model
it very easily could just be a 3d model
that they tracked and he just kind of
grabs the air he's like huh
i'm just saying that wizard barfing
video that we made like decades ago
is like that it's just that's like the
cooler version of the wizards barfing
and i personally prefer the frozen
bullets coming out of the gun
you know the ice coming out of the gun
there like growing almost looks
practical it's so well done
yeah like the yellow light shining
through it plus like the cold blue light
of like the flashlight on the gun
also shining through it it really sells
that it's ice being transparent like
that
yeah i can tell they have a really good
action design team
all the visual effects are like so much
cooler because of that it definitely
seems that
from the get go they are planning for
the effects to complement the
choreography
let's look at that cg fire like this
fire looks pretty decent
getting the color for fire right is hard
to do it's still not quite there like
when he throws his hand down
like that looks weird like murky yellow
looking behind him at the fire over his
shoulder like that's
what the colors oh yeah you're totally
right fire in the background is how
blown out it should be
like look look at how blown out the fire
is in this dragon shot it's got a nice
hot core to it where the most fire is
and then as it kind of cools off and
goes towards the edges you get more of
that saturation of color back
it's just a really well-crafted shot to
make that feel real
overall i'm hopeful for this movie
seriously this is
this is super cool like this is just
like a playground for cool vfx
on day one there were two people and
then four
and then sixteen so i haven't seen
contagion i when i watched it in the
theaters i was like this is gonna be
cool it's gonna be like a zombie movie
and there's like no this is just kind of
sad
everyone got sick well it's because it's
the realistic take on what a pandemic
would actually
do if it was legitimately like killing
everyone
this is at the very end of the movie but
it takes place before the movie starts
this is kind of like revealing how the
pandemic started following this bat
and so that's what they're proposing is
that it was a combination of the bat and
a pig
crossing over their own viruses that
eventually passes over to humans
and that is what caused the deadly virus
in this movie but if we go back and look
at those bats
hey guess what not a single one of those
bats were real
that didn't that didn't even cross my
mind so that's a cg bat it's a cg bat
it's the real footage plate of the
bananas behind it and they manipulated
the bananas to move with the bat
but it's like it's just really well done
the animation's
really well done exactly the animation
is so good because they realize
bats never move smoothly it's always
just like
they did all of the animation in maya
and guess what render engine they used
to render this bat
metal ray that's it it's mental ray oh
yes
did mental rays my jam mentor is what i
grew up on kind of
it became famous after the first
spider-man film because i used it on
that
the the studio that did this bat the
previous bat they did was for tropic
thunder right before jablinski games ate
the bat
they had some batting practices what
you're trying to say
[Music]
outside the fact that the bat is
animated really really well and modeled
really well with fur and all that kind
of stuff
the way they directed these shots like
it's lit like an actual
shot of somebody sitting there trying to
get a bat to fly into a banana it's even
soderburg's not there going
i need to see the bat come on bring the
bat out they're like yeah but there's no
lights he didn't like the scene he's
like i don't care
like stephen soderbergh is clearly going
like just make it look real what's the
biggest bat
oh dude i will tell you what is the
biggest bat a flying fox there in
australia
they're like three feet wide they
literally look like dragons
what that looks like a dude in a costume
species so i pull up this clip because
there's some weird stuff in here
yeah all right so they're definitely
doing a little face warp here a little
andrew cameron demon face effect
hey what's up andrew kramer here i think
oh his arm's getting a lot longer he's
got spikes for a head also all these
shots are locked off you'll notice
they turned off all the extra variables
so they can just focus on the thing
they're doing
it doesn't look completely dead because
it's on film and you get a little bit
like that
film gate weave if you guys talk too
much about like motion tracking film
like that
no when you're trying to motion track
film
even if your camera is on a tripod
there's still
movement because each frame of that film
as it's flying
through the gate there's just tiny tiny
little inconsistencies
with a film basically either going back
and forth
or of it going up and down and so it's
incredibly difficult especially if you
want an
object to just sit there in this nice
locked off shot it's like no
there's still movement you have to match
that like fine fine fine wiggle that
happens in the film i don't know how
they dealt with that
i don't think they did i don't think
they did either i think you just get
wiggle
oh man it's not even a shadow on the
rock
h.r geiger actually did all the designs
for this you see the inspiration for
aliens which are also designed
by h.r geiger
so alien looks a little weird you know
you're like ah it's not realistic
looking why doesn't why does it look
real there
what's wrong with that shot why does it
not look real motion
no motion blur on the face the arc of
the jump is way off
it looks like it's doing a leap forwards
and then it doesn't like move forwards
right so motion blur lighting all the
traditional issues okay but like
how do you think this is animated you
maybe do some motion capture motion
capture is not even really a thing back
in 1995 no
not at all actually it is a thing in
1995 and i think
i think this is the first motion capture
really
so it's not motion capture with a person
though
so there's a motion capture puppet they
made that's basically
a full like recreation of the alien with
tiny
like sensors in all the joints that they
had
rigged up to a 3d model of the creature
so you could basically puppet this tiny
like little robot doll
and get your animation isn't that crazy
that's victory that's actually really
smart it wasn't like there was animation
software for
doing humanoids in an easy way like you
could do it but you have to sit there
and brute force your way through it
so they just like jumped a whole like
five to ten years forward in software
technology by setting up a puppet
that now basically recreates what we can
do in the computer it's funny how like
none of it panned out
you know that's that's the joke here is
that like it still looks like
janky like hand animate i hate to say
janky once again we're talking about
this movie
like 25 years in the future i will also
say i bet you that shot for as janky as
it looks
the motion would be way jankier if it
wasn't that puppet system
i bet you'd look like lawnmower man yeah
i think you're right
now seeing the context behind this alien
i i love it
but it just i feel like the final
execution doesn't quite work
you know i want to see more ancient
visual effects all the way back from the
90s so leave a comment down below
suggesting what we should take a look at
i want to see these visual effects
inscribed onto mayan temples
let's react to that maybe you'd like to
meet a friend of mine
ed 209 whoa i watched robocop for the
first time this weekend
i really enjoyed it now it's time to
erase that mistake
emotion blur yeah you know for
how janky it is like it's so cool
this guy's got feet and he's still oh oh
hey good for you
[Laughter]
that's it like that's the point of this
movie it's like everyone thinks it's
like a badass action film but it's like
it's a comedy it's yeah it's super weird
although i will say
their track mats are excellent like the
opening shot when he walks into the room
like it actually looks like it's part of
the scene
one thing you'll note is that any time
there's stop motion in these shots
the quality the overall quality of the
film around it goes down like see how
he's like that guy's skin tone
is like kind of faded and desaturated
and yellow i wonder if
they actually didn't do track mattes i
wonder if it's actually rear projection
and the stop motion oh my god that would
solve it that'd be so much easier and it
would also explain the degraded color
of the film we have one of the all-star
teams the special effects
oh that's it is we were projected hey we
called it
that's actually that's super cool that's
a good catch
look at that that's sweet they're
literally projecting the image
and then recording that with another
camera and hoping it like looks good
it's like the equivalent of like ripping
a movie by going to the theater and
recording it with the camera i was gonna
say
exactly that that's exactly that there's
some great touches to how they're doing
these shots though
like the first shot when it walks out
and it's dark and then the lights turn
on
like what a cool way to have like the
lighting interact and like really make
it feel real
at what point in the movie does he start
shooting all the dicks
actually he does shoot the guy's dick
off for real that happens once in the
movie and then they took that joke and
then they made a whole other video over
it
wait i thought i thought when he shoots
them all that's in the movie no that
scene
is a remade scene uh there's this like
group of filmmakers called fatal farm
they took
the scene where he saves the woman from
the rapist
they remade it so well that ren thought
their remade scene was part of the
original film it was a lot more
a lot more dick than i would have liked
to have seen in a day
oh and then the horde comes then the
horde
so the reason i'm crying is because we
just watched a scene that we can't show
on the youtube channel
but uh you can watch it on
corridordigital.com it's not safe for
any work it's 18 plus and very relevant
to robocop
yep
[Music]
subscribe
[Laughter]
this is the future of american justice
so we saw what old robocop looks like
let's just take a look at what new
robocop looks like here
wasn't this this is the one that just
basically lost all the irony
of the original
they're like let's oh ng robocop dude
this is like angsty teenager robocop
physics if physics don't matter then why
should we care about anything
it's hard to pinpoint like what these
scenes don't really make me feel
anything
it's hard to figure out i feel like it's
because the impacts are still too small
and too puffy like the explosions how
big those impact should be
a great reference is the pearl harbor
scene from michael bay's pearl harbor
like look at those squibs look at the
thickness of the smoke look at how
defined they are look at
how fast they're moving and you compare
that to like little spark hits in
the robocop the cg robocop and it's like
when the spark hit is as big as two of
my hands going like this it's not big
enough
it's also one of those things of like
you set up the scene like we want the
scene where like three mechs are
fighting robocop and everyone's got full
auto guns and we're blasting everything
what it would look like is people would
shoot their guns for like 10 seconds and
then there'd just be this thick cloud of
smoke so it's gonna be really foggy for
the rest of the scene
the scene kind of forces them into a
corner where they can't
get realistic with the hit effects but
you kind of need to embrace that and let
that be
your scene let it become thick and full
of smoke another thing they could have
done is
not have the robot shoot fully automatic
guns and have instead like
treat them like they're candid so every
shot is just like
god's fist punching the wall you know or
punching at robocop so
like you can anticipate each one and
it's like if one of those hits you
you're dead
versus like oh just keep running they're
tickling me it's like each one's just
taking
one off of his health bar you know
one
so today's episode is brought to you by
audible but really this is just an
excuse to talk about one of my favorite
books of all time
the way of kings by brandon sanderson
because one of my life goals is to get
as many people into the cosmere as
possible
in this book oh my god you guys are in
for a roller coaster
of entertainment imagine a world that is
attacked by storms every other week
there's this massive storm that
literally throws boulders through the
sky
and you have these warring countries and
they have these plates of armor that are
like
giant impenetrable samurai suits and
they have what are called sharp blades
imagine a sword that's like six feet
long
that can cut through anything without
resistance imagine cutting through
a giant like five foot thick steel wall
as if it's butter
it's kind of like a lightsaber but
better and if it cuts through flesh
it doesn't actually cut the flesh it
just kills the flesh it's so cool
trust me it's amazing you will not be
disappointed if you want to get this
book the way of kings is the first book
of the stormlight archive all you got to
do is go to audible.com corto crew or
simply text corridor crew to 500 500
and you will get a free 30-day trial and
of course you'll get the entire plus
catalog which includes
thousands upon thousands of audiobooks
podcasts
originals of course you'll get that free
credit every single month with the plus
membership you don't have to just
download you can stream them directly
from
the app it's very handy thank you so
much for watching let's get back to some
vfx that we are using our
eyeballs to shift up and down depending
on how we feel
thank you so much for watching we're
here every saturday and every sunday
slash other days of the week for other
videos i put out too so go ahead and
check those out consider checking them
out
they're really cool so you guys want to
see my list oh these are all from the
comments i'm going to scroll really fast
so you can't see
what these are but i got a lot i got a
lot dude the whole contagion bat thing i
took from the comments
it's so cool seeing the movies that you
recommend because
we get to see new stuff things we never
even dreamed of seeing or watching
and i don't know it's cool we learn you
learn
it's a win-win